et pour en parler nous sommes sur ce
plateau avec alexis poulain bonsoir
alexis merci d'avoir rejoint alors ce
soir premier débat des candidats à l'air
un débat attendu en cela fait un petit
moment ça cet accouchement se fait voilà
peut-être pas dans la douleur mais enfin
tout cas il est lent quelles vont être
les thèmes abordés alors il y aura
quatre débats déjà c'est le premier de
un mois de débats donc oui ça va être
long il ya peut-être une overdose de
candidats à l'air à la fin du mois de
novembre en tout cas ces lycées soit
peut-être à l'usure sans doute ils vont
parler bien sûr de l'immigration et
vivent la langue du pouvoir d'achat
évidemment l'économie qui sera au coeur
des débats mais aussi du régalien
l'autorité puisque c'est un thème de la
droite et j'imagine les le thème central
sera celui du pouvoir d'achat puisqu'on
en parle évidemment beaucoup en ce
moment aujourd'hui et sans doute s'est
invitée bien sûr encore une attaque face
à la police donc le thème de la sécurité
qui va être également centrale à ces
débats des candidats aient l'air alors
ils sont cinq ils ont les parrainages et
on va aller voir et demain ils vont se
retrouver tous ensemble d'ailleurs après
le débat autour de la tombe du général
de gaulleà pour montrer combien ils sont
soudés parce que l'exercice est
difficile qu'il s'agit de montrer qu'ils
sont pas d'accord mais qu'ils ne sont
pas frères ennemis voilà donc c'est
délicat alors elle est pas facile parce
que coincé entre le rnd moore toujours
pas déclaré on attendait sur notre
antenne ce soir mais enfin voilà
toujours pas lui aussi c'est long et
macro un couloir étroit pour une future
candidate ou un boulevard plutôt
programmatique oui alors c'est compliqué
pour les républicains parce que
traditionnellement on entend dire que la
france est à droite donc c'est vrai
qu'il ya un électorat assez puissant et
d et d'ailleurs des régions des villes
des départements enfin vraiment d un
parti qui est ancré dans le territoire
donc pour eux voir l'arrivée d'un
zemmour qui
chamboule totalement la donne qui pousse
tout le monde y compris
et rennes le rennes ils étaient habitués
finalement c'était pas très compliqué
une vigne rouge certains l'avait franchi
comme monsieur mariani eric ciotti
maintenant parle de zemmour donc il ya
toujours un une ligne rouge flou et puis
emmanuel macron surtout qui a totalement
revu la donne puisqu'il se fait élire
par ce qu'il reste du ps en quelque
sorte avec ce ni droite ni gauche qui
était quand même issue plutôt du parti
socialiste et il gouverne depuis 2010
est à droite en volant tous les thèmes
des l'air en essayant de d'ailleurs
d'être colmater les brèches 1 puisqu'il
n'était pas très fort sur le régalien la
sécurité la défense la police et on l'a
vu à chaque fois essayé et bien de
montrer qu'il était bon sur ces thèmes
là pour ne pas prêter le flanc aux
critiques donc pour les républicains
évidemment c'est s'est montré la
différence se démarquer tout en disant
qu'ils sont meilleurs alors qu'ils sont
dans l'opposition et c'est un party les
républicains qui n'a pas l'habitude de
l'opposition et on voit bien ils sont
gênés puisqu'ils ne peuvent pas défendre
un bilan montré que ce qu'ils ont fait
est que le bilan qu'il ya eu il a été
siphonné en partie par emmanuel macron
avec des personnes comme edward feeling
qui lance un nouveau parti mais aussi
bruno le maire enfin tous les ténors
anciennement de la droite qui sont
maintenant au gouvernement est ce que ça
veut dire que vous êtes en train de nous
parler de du chant du cygne très
républicain il ya encore de l'espoir
alors il ya toujours l'espoir donc il ya
de la vie il ya de l'espoir et ya de la
vie puisque il ya de nombreux
nouveau encartés qui prennent justement
leur adhésion au parti pour pouvoir
voter lors du congrès surtout en région
parisienne d'ailleurs alors est ce que
ça va changer la donne plutôt avantagé
valérie pécresse qui est élu de la
région parisienne mais on voit bien que
il ya un vrai schisme profond qui ne va
pas être résolue avec ces débats celui
de savoir si une partie de la droite
centriste va aller avec emmanuel macron
va accepter finalement pour des postes
ministériels ou simplement parce que le
pouvoir est là et qui menait le
maquereau en se représentant va sans
doute faire un appel du pied une
alliance nationale face à la crise que
nous vivons on connaît un peu la chanson
et puis une autre branche qui regarde du
côté d'eric zemmour pas forcément du
rassemblement national mais rim on n'a
pas le nom de le pen c'est un
éditorialiste du figaro même s'il a un
discours plus radical que marine le pen
il peut séduire des électeurs de droite
et aussi des politiques de droite parce
que justement égal à cet appel du pied
d'eric zemmour rpr les en moi je veux
faire ce retour à cette droite des
valeurs la droite des années 80 l'effort
l'économie et puis
une ligne très dur sur l'immigration et
je ne vois pas comment aujourd'hui dans
un parti même si ce soir ils vont
débattre ensemble on va pouvoir mettre à
la fois xavier bertrand eric ciotti
réponse dans quelques heures voire
quelques jours voire quelques mois merci
alexis poulain d'avoir été avec nous